dizem que é mais fácil encontrar o amor
da sua vida do que uma vaga para
estacionar o setor comercial sul teve um
tempo que eu acreditei início achava que
realmente faltava vaga para estacionar
em brasília que realmente nossa podiam
fazer um estacionamento ali desmatar
umas árvores ali pavimentar até entender
que na verdade o objetivo de ninguém
achar uma vaga para estacionar
o objetivo das pessoas e chegar num
lugar
se ela chegar a pé de bicicleta carona
metrô ônibus
a preocupação com a vaga de
estacionamento desaparece e aí dá um
tempo eu percebi que na ótica das
pessoas que já andam bastante em
brasília
não tá faltando vaga para estacionar tá
sobrando porque não tem uma vaga que não
seja uma calçada uma grama onde jardim
algum momento do dia ea gente vai
percebendo com o espaço público e vai
sendo utilizado de maneira estranha às
vezes no espaço de uma vaga para carro
dá pra estacionar 7 a 10 bicicletas
dá para montar uma banca de jornal dá
para botar uma lanchonete da rua pra ter
muito mais vida naquele espaço que
geralmente fica ocioso oito horas por
dia e quando ele está sendo usado
geralmente usado por uma pessoa só para
se transportar quando a gente vai
percebendo essas questões
a gente vê que as possibilidades de uso
do espaço público são muitas ea gente
percebe que não está faltando vaga para
estacionar
está faltando a vida nos estacionamentos
da cidade a gente pode vir a ter várias
opções de uso ea gente vai conversando
sobre elas ao longo da apresentação
a falta de vaga em brasília é um dos
mitos que precisa ser quebrado pra gente
dá conta de transformar a mobilidade
nessa cidade e ao longo dessa
apresentação ele vai quebrar outros três
mitos dizem que o tombamento da cidade
atrapalha a modernização do transporte
será porque quem fala isso parece que
ignora que a cidade que são mais
reconhecidos no mundo por terem sistema
de transporte excelente sou muito mais
antigas que brasília e tem centros
históricos muito mais bem preservados
o tombamento não atrapalha o ônibus de
passar no horário atrapalha o ônibus e
limpa
impede a implementação de bilhete único
quem sabe até onde está em fazer nada
disso é impedido e parece que essa
discussão sobre o tombamento é feita de
um jeito ou para manter tudo do jeito
que tá ou porque quer se beneficiar por
alguns interesses imobiliários e
transformar um pouco a configuração da
cidade
e aí quem faz essa discussão às vezes
fala não
a questão é que falta espaço para carro
na cidade por isso que tem tanto
congestionamento
cíntia larga nas vias fizeram os túneis
fizeram os viadutos aí o trânsito vai
fluir e aí acreditando nisso se fazem
passar orientações com as melhores
intenções que têm os piores resultados
como consequência acreditando nisso a
gente em vez de encurtar o tempo perdido
nos congestionamentos acaba tendo como
conseqüência aumentando porque o que
acontece é que a gente vai ampliando as
distâncias percorridas aumentando a
poluição do ar aumentam a degradação do
espaço público aumentando a sua
qualidade no trânsito
aqui em brasília por ano a gente perde
13 dias em congestionamento
se a gente comparar com outras cidades a
gente pode achar muita gente compara
ocorreu em são paulo ela já perdem um
mês inteiro
o período que a gente acha nas férias
mas trajando um mês
olha só se a gente tivesse outro estilo
de vida a gente tinha um mês por ano no
caso em brasília 13 dias por ano pra
fazer outras atividades
e aí na hora que a gente vai ver como é
que a gente organiza a cidade para dar
conta de construir uma cidade que de
fato seja mais interessante uma das
argumentações que aparece falando não
mas é por que investir em transporte
público é muito caro e aí a gente não
percebe que na verdade se gasta 12 vezes
mais o transporte individual motorizado
do que com políticas de transporte
público dentro disso basicamente grosso
é justamente à infraestrutura do espaço
viário a pavimentação que um gasto de
urbanização altíssimo e geralmente é
dedicado majoritariamente por uso de
veículos motorizados individuais
a boa notícia é que a gente não precisa
continuar refém dessa situação é ela não
é uma catástrofe natural que basta
aceitar a gente tem chance de fazer uma
situação diferente para o uso do espaço
urbano para o tipo de vida que a gente
quer te permite mais isso então tem que
falar sobre o central que é metrô e brt
é ônibus é bicicleta e se a gente vai
ter que debater meios de transporte o
meio de transporte às vezes a gente não
percebe que a solução antes disso não
vai ficar remendando na qual meio de
transporte é mais rápido mais econômico
que menos polui que transportam mais
gente por hora/sentido e cada vez mais
forte é claro que não é que tem suas
vantagens e desvantagens não pode nunca
ficar refém de um só
a gente tem que perceber é que uma
dessas soluções pra gente trabalhar com
o meio de transporte é pensar na
perspectiva das pessoas e como elas usam
o espaço urbano
enquanto a gente tiver uma concentração
tão grande de emprego no plano piloto é
um bairro demora tão pouca gente não tem
meios de transporte sozinho que dê conta
da situação
gente olha só águas claras tem 4 400
moradores do plano piloto têm emprego em
águas claras para metade dos moradores
a gente vai pra ceilândia tem quase
quatro vezes mais moradores com a mesma
quantidade de emprego
se a gente não percebe que a gente tem
que associar política de mobilidade com
política habitacional com o mercado de
trabalho com a descentralização de opção
de lazer
a gente vai ficar reféns sempre de
remendar as consequências de uma
situação e refém do debate de promédio
de transporte ou melhor sem perceber que
cada um pode ter um papel para situações
diferentes dentro da cidade
se a gente não percebe isso que acontece
isso aqui o metrô de são paulo linha
vermelha que foi construído ligando e
paquera ao centro da cidade por várias
por várias óticas investir no metrô
excelente porque é um meio de transporte
que não depende de combustível fóssil é
o que mais tem capacidade de transportar
pessoas por hora sentido mas se você não
associa isso é uma política urbana o
resultado é que você construiu por uma
por uma época a linha de metrô mais
lotada da américa latina e hoje em dia a
mais lotada do mundo em termos de
lotação de pessoas por metro quadrado a
gente passou toque o pastor moscou
passou pequim para xangai
a gente não debate modelo de cidade
o que a gente está construindo ea gente
quer continuar segregando as pessoas
segregando os usos dos espaços a gente
vai ficar reféns sempre de remendar uma
situação de evitar uma notícia boa
além de que a gente não é refém dessa
situação é que a solução para mudar esse
quadro
ela é muito fácil de ser implementada em
termos de conhecimento
a gente já sabe o que tem que fazer são
implementada por por conta da ótica de
que orienta gente na hora de tomar as
decisões
a gente percebe o que a gente gosta de
fazer desde criança quer brincar na rua
e que a gente gosta de fazer quando
adulto que ainda uma feira
a gente já tem muito fácil é o tipo de
cidade que a gente quer viver com o tipo
de cidade que a gente valoriza que a
gente acha que é a mais adequada
o pulo do gato é perceber que ocupação
que a gente faz os espaços públicos em
ocasiões especiais
ela não precisa acontecer só em ocasiões
especiais
não é só no dia de domingo que a gente
pode fazer uma cidade um espaço mais
humano - motorizado
a gente percebe que essas ocasiões
especiais na verdade elas podem ser
vivenciadas cotidianamente se a gente
mudar algumas premissas das decisões que
a gente toma tamo tanto em termos de
decisões individuais como temos decisões
de investimento de política pública a
gente percebe que tem uma saída
relativamente tranquila é pra cidade e
tranquila no sentido de ser fácil de
implementar não incomodar ninguém às
vezes incomoda porque tem gente que se
beneficia é do caos urbano do jeito que
ele está colocado hoje mas a gente
percebe que é alcançável é realizável
mesmo às vezes passando por uma fase de
transição de incômodo de alguns setores
que se beneficiam com a situação como
ela está hoje a gente vai dar conta de
sair daquele mito das pessoas que falam
que brasília foi construída para os
carros que chega um ponto que não
importa mais se foi ou não foi
construída para os carros o que importa
é que ela não precisa mais continuar
sendo para os carros